ننوه الى هذه الاخبار العاجله للناطق
العسكري لانصار الله الحوثيين يقول
استهدفنا سفينه نفطيه بريطانيه في خليج
عدن بعدد من الصواريخ ايضا اضاف بان
الاصابه كانت مباشره وادت الى احتراق
سفينه النفط هذا تطور جديد فيما يتعلق
باستهداف السفن في البحر الاحمر من قبل
الحوثيين استهداف سفي نفط بريطانيه في
خليج عدن بعدد من الصواريخ والاصابه كانت
كما يقول الحوثيون مباشره وادت الى احتراق
سفينه
النفط قال المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده ستيفن دوجاريك ان الامين
العام انطونيو جوتيريش سيحيل فورا الاخطار
بالتدابير المؤقته لمحكمه العد الدوليه
الى مجلس الامن الدولي واضافت دوجاريك في
مؤتمر صحفيا ان جوتيريش يؤكد ان قرارات
محكمه العد الدوليه ملزمه وهو على ثقه ان
جميع الاطراف ستلتزم بها بموجب ميثاق
الامم المتحده والنظام الذي انشئت بموجبه
المحكمه كما اوضح ان موقف الامين العام
للامم المتحده واضح بشان استقلاليه محكمه
العد الدوليه وكان قد طالب بوقف اطلاق
النار لاهداف انسانيه واحترام القانون
الدولي الانساني وطلب باطلاق سراح
الرهان
يعني معنا الان من الامم المتحده مراسه
الجزيره مراد هاشم هذا التطور
الجديد فيما يتعلق باختار الامين العام
للامم المتحده فورا كما قال دوجاريك اختار
مجلس الامن بالقرارات والتدابير التي صدرت
عن محكمه العاده الدوليه هل هذا اجراء
عادي ام وفق الظ ظروف التي تعيشها المنطقه
هنا والقتل المستمر في
غزه مرحبا جمال
هو اجراء وخطوه اجرائيه بموجب ميثاق الامم
المتحده والنظام الاساسي
لمحكمه ذاته وهي كانت خطوه بالتالي مرتقب
انه ف فور صدور الحكم الابتدائي من محكمه
العدل ايا كان هذا الحكم فان الامين العام
بطبيعه الحال سيخطر مجلس الامن اي مجرد
اشعار وابلاغ بهذا الحكم ومحتواه واللافت
ان الامين العام في
بيانه تعقيبا على صدور هذا الحكم لم يطلق
او يبدي اي تعليق او موقف ان بالدعم او
الترحيب ولكنه اكتفى
ب في البيان الذي تلاه المتحدث باسمه بانه
احيط علما
وارفقت هذه العباره اي انه احيط علما
بكافه الاحكام
التي صدرت اليوم عن محكمه العدل الدوليه
لكنه فصل فيما تعنيه الماده الثانيه من
اتفاقيه منع الاباده الجماعيه وكان هذا
امرا لافتا وهي ماده تشير الى انه يجب
الامتناع بشكل كلي او جزئ جزئي عن اعمال
تقود الى الاباده الجماعيه ضد جماعه محدده
اثنيه و عرقيه وخلاف ذلك ولكن مراد اكد
على قض على كلمه ملزمه يعني هذه القرار
الصادره على المحكمه العدل الدوليه قال
ملزمه و وهنا حينما ترسل هذه القرارات
لمجلس الامن هل سيفرضها بالقوه مجلس الامن
في حال نكثت اسرائيل هي في الواقع ولم
يعني ولم تلتزم بهذه
القرارات هي ملزمه بالفعل اي محكمه العدل
الدولي هي احدى هيئات الامم المتحده احدى
الهيئات الرئيسيه في الامم المتحده وجميع
اعضاء الامم المتحده هم اعضاء في هذه
الهيئه وتنص الماده 93 من ميثاق الامم
المتحده على انه يتعين على الدول الاعضاء
حينما تحتكم الى المحكمه في نزاعاتها ان
ان تلتزم باي حكم يصدر عن هذه المحكمه وان
تقوم بتنفيذه وانه في حال امتنع احد
الطرفين عن التنفيذ فان الطرف المتضرر
الطرف الاخر يلجا الى مجلس الامن لاتخاذ
تدابير من اجل تنفيذ هذا الحكم اي ان
المساله تعود الى مجلس الامن الدولي في
النهايه وكما هو معروف قراراته دائما
مرهونه اما بتوفر الاغلبيه
تس اوات او عدم وجود مع الاغلبيه عدم وجود
فيتو بشان اعتماد اي قرار او احكام من
محكمه العدل جمال شكرا لك مراد هاشم مراسل
الجزيره متحدثا من مقر الامم المتحده في
نيويورك شكرا لك